[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERICA CHUONG: Hi, everyone.
I'm Erica Chuong, a customer
engineer at Google Cloud.
Welcome back to Google Cloud
Technical Guides for Startups,
a video series designed for
startup technical enablement
to help startups to
start, build, and grow
their businesses
successfully and sustainably
on Google Cloud.
This episode focuses
on how you can
make the most of Google Cloud
through various startup offers.
In this video,
we're going to cover
Google for Startups
Program for startups
from preseed to series A,
what the program entails,
eligibility requirements, and
best practices, the Migration
Incentive Program for startups
post-series A on another Cloud
platform, and best practices
and resources for your startup.
So without any
further ado, let's
get right into
exploring the benefits
and resources of Google
for Startups Cloud Program
together.
Our current program supports
your startup's growth
with Google for
Startups Cloud Program.
Investor-backed startups
get financial, technical,
and business support
that scales with them.
They'll build with
intelligent, cost-effective,
proven technology that can
enable startups to move fast.
As part of the program,
they can upskill their team.
On the technical support
side, our startup success team
is in place as a
dedicated resource
to connect with program
members to ensure
that they have the
technical support they
need to successfully
build their businesses.
This program features access
to our customer engineers
to help with architecture
reviews, troubleshooting,
and even invitations
to technical training
and certification
programs, as well
as support and documentation.
They can also get
a financial boost.
Startups that are
accepted into the program
will get their first year
with Google Cloud covered up
to a total of $100,000 USD.
In year two, they'll get 20%
of Google Cloud usage covered,
also up to $100,000 USD.
This program is designed
to help startups to get off
the ground when they may
need it the most and then
on to a sustainable growth
path for the future.
We also see a lot of
startups using credits
to test new features
or try out products
such as Looker or Firebase.
Details and conditions
can be found
at cloud.google.com/startup.
They can also receive
business support.
You'll get tailored support
from our startup success
team and our sales teams with
a single point of contact
to help you navigate Google,
attend special events,
meet Google engineers
and specialists,
and even connect
with startup peers
solving similar challenges
in the Google Cloud startup
community.
They may even be comarketing
opportunities with startups
that you can be invited
to cocreate a case study
or be featured in a blog post.
Now that we've gone over what
the Google for Startups Cloud
Program is, let's talk
about how to qualify for it.
All customers must be funded
with publicly verifiable equity
investments up to and
including preseed, angel seed,
and series A. If
series A, this must
have been raised within
the past 12 months.
They must also have been founded
within 10 years of applying
to the program and have a
publicly available company
website and a unique
company email domain.
If you need to create
a custom email account,
sign up for Google Workspace.
You must also have a valid
Google Cloud billing account
ID linked to the
domain and company
email on your application.
Additionally, a
customer must not
be already enrolled in the
Google for Startups Cloud
Program or have received
in excess of $4,000 USD
in Google Cloud credits.
You must also not be a company
who has IPOed or been acquired
or an educational institution,
government entity,
nonprofit, personal blog, dev
shop, consultancy, or agency.
You must also not be a crypto
mining company or a company
distributing tokens contrary
to regulatory guidance
in your jurisdiction.
For example, companies
issuing tokens solely
for speculative purposes
will not be considered.
Apply at
cloud.google.com/startup
and accept the program
terms and conditions.
Your application will
be routed for review
to ensure we can
validate your identity
and confirm eligibility.
If accepted, credits
are activated
in the billing account
provided in the application.
And an email
notification is sent
to the applicant with an
overview of the program.
If we cannot accept
your application,
an email notification is sent
to the applicant with more
information and guidance on
how to remedy the issues.
Google for Startups
Cloud credits
carry the same scope as most
other Cloud credit programs
in 2022.
They can be used for Google
Cloud Services like BigQuery
and Cloud Run.
It can also be used for other
offerings, such as Looker
and Actifio.
In addition, these
credits can be
used for Firebase
and support services.
Check out the links
in the description
box below for more details.
Google for Startups
Cloud credits
will not cover the cost
of third-party marketplace
licenses.
Workspace, Maps, and Qwiklabs
benefits are managed separately
and can be redeemed
by eligible startups
by emailing
Cloudstartupsupport@google.com.
Let's go over some best
practices for your application.
Verifying your identity
is the first step
to apply for Google for
Startups Cloud Program.
This process helps us to
protect you and your company
and ensure the correct startups
are enrolling in the program.
Here are some pro tips to
help us do this step quickly
and efficiently.
Apply with your startup's
business email address,
not a personal one.
For example, use
app@coolstartup.com, not
coolstartup@gmail.com.
Ensure your email address
and business domain
on the application matches.
Next, provide an active
Google Cloud billing ID.
Example on the screen.
Make sure that you have an
individual Google Cloud billing
ID that is just for
your singular company.
While we're on the
subject of billing IDs,
use a billing ID that
your company controls.
The owner of the billing account
must have the same email domain
as the email and domain
used on the application.
Check your startup's funding.
Your startup must have
received preseed to series
A equity funding.
And if series A,
that funding must
have occurred within one year
of applying to that program.
Provide documentation of
equity investments via publicly
available online sources.
Examples include reputable news
articles, investment aggregator
sites, and investment
portfolio posts.
We can not accept
confidential information
and/or social media posts
from your own company.
Please remember to double check
all parts of the application
and eligibility requirements
prior to submitting.
And with that,
you're ready to go.
If your startup
is beyond series A
and looking to migrate across
from another cloud provider
or on-prem system,
this migration program
is the program for you.
Our migration
incentive program is
designed to support
later-stage startups
by offsetting costs of
migrating cloud services
and infrastructure
to Google Cloud.
Startups will receive high-touch
technical support to both plan
and execute the
migration and access
to instructor-led
and online training
to help ensure your team
has the required technical
capabilities.
Our Google Cloud engineers
and ecosystem partners
are ready to support you
and your migration journey.
Other benefits, such as
Google Workspace, Google Maps,
and Google Cloud
Skills Boost benefits
are also offered
to these startups.
And your account
manager will support you
in benefiting from these
incentives and beyond.
To learn more about the
migration incentive program,
please reach out to
your dedicated sales
team who could be
your personal guide
throughout the entire process.
You can be connected
to your sales team
at cloud.google.com/contacts.
Apply for the Google for
Startups Cloud Program today.
For Google Cloud
technical support,
such as bugs or quota requests,
or Google Cloud billing
support, such as invoices
and account administration,
sign up for our support plan
at cloud.google.com/support.
This support will allow you
to self-service file tickets
from within your
Google Cloud Console.
Also be sure to check out the
startup resource home page.
Link in the
description box below.
A couple of resources have been
added to the description box
below to help you
understand these programs
in further detail.
So be sure to check them out.
In the next episode, we'll cover
Cloud Firestore and Datastore,
including sample architecture
and a demonstration
of building a web application
powered by Firestore.
That brings us to
the end of this video
where we went over the
Google for Startups Program
and the migration
incentive program.
Stay tuned for all the
exciting and helpful content
that we have for you.
And don't forget to
like and subscribe
to our YouTube channel.
Click on the bell icon
to be notified each time
a new video is posted.
We hope to see you
soon in our next video.